certains inconvénients oui merci que
[Musique]
vous comprenez notre agenda et
excusez-moi de pour ce retard bonjour
chers collègues nos approches dans la
politique interne à 6 par le président
poutine dans ses discours tout à l'heure
dans son adresse à l'assemblée fédérale
je pourrais répéter que le monde
traverse une période de turbulence
turbulences dues à certains des actes
agressifs qu'ils disent la destruction
de leur architecture de sécurité dans le
monde et le remplacement du droit
international par certaines règles
c'est la sortie du traité est un f et
l'absence de volonté de prolonger le
traité new start la crise dans le golfe
et les tentatives de réactiver les
actions militaires allaient pratiquer
militaires au sein de l'otan ce déficit
de confiance et renforcé par des
sanctions unilatérales les conflits
armés
je pourrais citer les tentatives des
etats-unis de saper la construction de
notre image les états unis abritent le
siège des nations unies mais
malheureusement ils refusent aux membres
de différents pays
le droit d'assister à la réunion des
nations unies peut-être il s'agit des
nouvelles règles
prétendue nouvelle règle la diplomatie
russe poursuit ses actions qu'ils ont
été définis par le président russe qui
sont à la base de la désescalade eu des
crises internationales et nous essayons
de contribuer au maintien de la
stabilité internationale dans tous ces
espèces parmi nos priorités c'est la
lutte contre le terrorisme y compris en
syrie
la poursuite du processus politique dans
ce pays pour les intérêts du peuple
syrien
parmi les résultats de l'année dernière
c'est le lancement du processus
constitutionnel en syrie et le
rétablissement post conflits de ce pays
la réintégration de ce pays
dans la famille arabe nous avons
contribué au règlement des conflits en
libye au yémen dans une démarche
importante pourrait être l'initiative
heureuse de la sécurité collective dans
la région du golfe persique
nous l'avons proposé au sein d'une
colloque qui a réuni les représentants
des pays de la région
un autre priorité c'est aussi le
partenariat de avec nos partenaires
asiatiques dans le cadre de
l'organisation du traité de sécurité
collective organisation de coopération
de shanghai l'union économique
eurasiatique
nous avons signé un accord de libre
échange avec le vietnam l'année dernière
avec singapour et la serbie il ya eu des
accords de coopération entre l'union
économique eurasiatique avec la chine
nos poursuivants des négociations avec
israël et l'egypte est l'un des
calmant tout cela est conforme à
l'initiative du président poutine pour
être et le partenariat aux usa zia tic
ouvert pour tous les pays j'ai du
continent eurasiatique m nous avons
élargi notre coopération avec la chine
lors de la visite officielle en russie
du président sit-in peine
nous avons déclaré le début d'une
nouvelle époque ce qui stabilise la
situation dans le monde
nous poursuivons le partenariat
stratégique avec l'inde les pays de
l'oceane les pays de l'asie et de
l'amérique du sud
nous coopérons avec le continent
africain
en octobre dernier nous avons tenu le
premier sommet russie l'afrique dont le
bilan relance la coopération entre notre
pays et les pays africains
nous poursuivons nos efforts de
règlement de la crise en ukraine après
la pause de trois ans nous avons tenu le
sommet dans le format de la normandie
grâce aux efforts conjoints y compris et
des dirigeants ukrainiens
ces accords obtenus à paris nous avons
permettre de réaliser et les accords de
minsk
ce qui n'était pas possible sous le
régime de prochaine qu'on nous
poursuivons nos efforts pour prévenir la
course aux armements dans l'espace et la
sécurisation de cyber espace
nous allons employer le potentiel de g20
du brics du cee y ait de l'organisation
de coopération de shanghai
le groupe de cinq des membres permanents
du conseil de sécurité et l'organisme
clé puisque l'onu continue à être
l'organisme qui garantit la stabilité
dans le monde avec nos efforts sont
solidaires la majorité des pays et pour
conclure je vais souligné que cette
année nous allons célébrer 75 ans dans
la seconde guerre mondiale et 75 ans de
la création des nations unies nous
allons faire tout notre possible pour
empêcher la falsification de l'histoire
et est la réécriture de l'histoire pour
défendre la mémoire historique nous
sommes ensemble avec beaucoup de pays
je salue la contribution de nos
concitoyens qui résident dans les autres
pays nous invitons tous nos partenaires
pour les célébrations de ces dates la
région internationale de la chine
à vous la parole vous avez les numéros
oui comment ici nos jours merci monsieur
la preuve correspondant la corporation
russie chine et nous savons que à cette
année la russie la chine vont affecter
la 75e anniversaire de la victoire à
l'issue de la seconde guerre mondiale et
nous avons fait beaucoup afin de
construire cet ordre après la guerre à
quel est leur rôle aujourd'hui dans ces
stabilité globale et qu'est ce que vous
pouvez dire à propos de la coopération
entre les deux pays j'ai déjà évoqué une
relation stratégique avec la république
populaire de chine
nos approches sont similaires et quant à
tous les aspects de la vie
internationale nos évaluations n'ont vu
qui concerne le développement du monde
sont reflétées dans tout un nombre de
documents conjoint signé par le
président poutine et le président xi
jinping et nos relations ont atteint un
niveau stratégique
en témoignent les documents qui ont été
signés à moscou tout récemment nous
avons hautement nos démarches conjointes
au sein de du conseil de sécurité des
nations unies et nous défendons ensemble
les principes de la charte des lunes de
l'onu au conseil de sécurité lors de la
discussion autour des principes qui sont
les principes de base des nations unies
comme c'était récemment quand on a
examiné le problème de l'acheminement
acheminement de l'aide humanitaire
nous votons avec la chine tout en
défendant la justice et empêchons les
décisions et les solutions qui
pourraient être imposées par nos
collègues occidentaux dans le cadre de
leur agenda unilatéral qui ne prend pas
en compte les intérêts d'autres pays
j'ai évoqué la décision qui a été prise
compte tenu de la position de la russie
et de la chine sur le mécanisme de
l'aide humanitaire transfrontalière nos
collègues occidentaux essayer de faire
en sorte qu'on conserve un seul poste
d'acheminement de l'aide militaire à la
frontière de l'irak et de la série le
poste de et robbie
on prétendait que sans ce poste
d'acheminement les laisser ria serait en
détresse et ce sera une catastrophe
humanitaire
nous savons que ce n'est pas ça il est
vous avez l'intérêt de conserver ce
poste d'acheminement pour conserver la
présence des troupes américaines en
syrie est la présence illégale mais ce
qui se passe du point de vue de
l'acheminement de l'aide humanitaire à
la rive
o o est de leur as tu seulement se lève
en cours des mois d'octobre et de
novembre et les syriens ont acheminé
plus de 420 camions y compris cent
soixante deux tonnes de médicaments 120
camions en deux mois tandis qu en vingt
mois seulement 100 camions ont traversé
ce poste d'acheminement à la frontière
avec l'irak
c'est donc très peu c'est juste un
exemple qui montre qu'il ya une bonne
coopération un stratégique avec la
russie et les chinois et ensemble nous
défendons les fêtes et empêchant de
transformer le conseil de sécurité en
outil de pression sur les autres
intérêts sanaa la télévision syrienne
mais c'est la preuve est la crise
syrienne actuellement l'état quelle
étape qu'est ce qui ne permet pas de
résoudre cette crise est ce que c'est
possible de voir cette année le
rétablissement des relations entre la
syrie la turquie aide aux régions comme
dans l'union européenne
monde arabe la crise syrienne stade
avancé de règlement ya des progrès tous
azimuts qu'il s'agisse du volet
militaire politique humanitaire
le volet économique est un peu en retard
parce que nos partenaires occidentaux
certains pays de la région également
pose des préliminaires qui changent en
fonction de ce qui se passe parce que
certains disaient dès que le processus
politique est en route
on aura va lever nos limitations pour
l'économique le processus politique a
débuté était lancée ben ils disent
maintenant attendons les résultats de ce
processus politique est comme ça on va
augmenter le niveau de limitation de
temps ce qui ne contribue pas vraiment
au bon résultat mais l'essentiel c'est
que la grande victoire a été remportée
sur le terrorisme quelques petits îlots
de quelques petits îlots de dèche dans
la zone est
dans certaines zones il ya environ dix
mille combattants dèche qui sont encore
présents surtout dans les zones
contrôlées par la force dit démocratique
nous avons des informations selon
lesquelles les forces se dit
démocratique de la syrie laisse partir
en ce moment ces bandits qui vont
rejoindre d'autres pensées de la série
ceci est inquiétant nous avons prévenu
nos partenaires américains qui ont leur
influence sur les forces dites
démocratiques
eh bien nous leur avons demandé donc
pêché ce départ de ces criminels des
camps ensuite l'aide humanitaire j'ai
déjà mentionné la coopération du
gouvernement syrien avec le nu j'ai cité
cet exemple pour montrer qu'il n'y a pas
vraiment de cause pour conserver ce
mécanisme d'acheminement transfrontalier
sans les consultations avec le
gouvernement syrien cette aide
humanitaire permet aujourd'hui de créer
des conditions pour le retour des
réfugiés en temps nous apportons de
l'aide via les fondations onusienne mais
également sur la base bilatérale plus
syrienne nous cédons les syriens la
police militaire russe justement
présente nous aidons également à
organiser le à les conduits d'eau nous
cédons à rétablir les écoles et
établissements d'enseignement
nous appelons tous les pays à ne pas
politiser cette problématique à ne pas
créer d'obstacles politiques
humanitaires dans le volet politique
il y à déjà le résultat qui est la
création du comité constitutionnel se
commettaient a pu établir la commission
de la rédaction pour l'établissement de
textes deux séances ont déjà tenu la
troisième séance sera organisée
prochainement
le représentant spécial du secrétaire
général de l'onu péter hain scène
visitera prochainement damas j'espère
que ces contacts avec les dirigeants
syriens pourront établir l'agenda du
jour du comité constitutionnel
et bien sûr nous sommes persuadés qu'il
est nécessaire de corriger cette faute
cette erreur qu'ils étaient
permettrait lorsque la syrie en 2011 a
été exclu de la ligue des états arabes
il faut que la syrie puissent réintégrer
l familles arabes comme la présence
avait déjà dit rails mais sur la drogue
bonjour enrayer la télévision italienne
depuis longtemps nous parlons de la
crise libyenne selon vous quelles sont
les erreurs faites par un gouvernement
italien ces dernières années concernant
la libye et qu'est ce que nous en tant
qu'italien pourrait faire actuellement
à la différence de ce qui a déjà été
fait et qu'est ce que vous attendez de
la conférence à berlin
quant aux erreurs
leur principal n'a pas été fait par
l'italie mais cette erreur a été faite
par nos collègues de l'otan ou le rôle
principal en 2011
cette prise de décision de bombarder les
libyens de renverser le régime
c'est pas l'italie qui a joué ce rôle je
vais pas nommer les leaders de cette
histoire cette histoire aventurière tout
le monde connaît qui étaient ces
personnes
depuis l'état les biens a été détruit
qu'on n'arrive toujours pas à rétablir
il ya eu des tentatives d'aider les
parties à la crise libyenne a retrouvé
la concorde pour faire venir la série à
la normale il y avait cet accord de
ceyrat qui
toujours considéré comme un accord
valable qui contenait les principes de
du règlement libyen et on pourra bien
sûr ajouter certaines notes certaines
nuances
il ya eu des accords également les
accords d'abou dhabi au début de l'année
dernière sur le rétablissement du
pouvoir en libye
rien n'a été réalisé elle a été mise en
pratique il ya eu ensuite la conférence
de paris et il ya eu même la date des
élections qui a été validé cette
conférence qui devait avoir lieu en mon
débit mais malheureusement faux faut
toujours il ne faut jamais trop avancé
trop attendre les résultats pratiques la
diplomatie est un processus très
progressif il ya eu cette conférence
palermo ou travail valable organisé
alors en répondant à la proposition de
nos collègues turcs nous avons essayé
d'apporter notre rapport à cette
solution règlement nous avons invité les
dirigeants et bien libye est libre où
est ils ont accepté notre proposition
nous avons passé sept heures ou même
plus à mener ces négociations avec les
délégations du maréchal haftar et du
président du parlement
saleh mais le monsieur sa rage également
les ministres
de l'autre côté le chef du conseil
d'état nous sommes arrivés à un texte
qui est équilibré à mon avis qu'ils
appellent l' association d'utilité au
cessez-le-feu
sarah jamie ch le monsieur sa rage
monsieur me fléron signé ce texte mais
de marshall haftar et monsieur salle et
ont demandé un peu plus de temps ont
signé ce document
disons que le feu est observé qu'ils
étaient
annoncé avant la moscow donc nous
espérons que ce régime de cessez le feu
va être prolongé récemment avec kogas
ministre allemand des affaires
étrangères rencontrer le maréchal haftar
avait gaz il a annoncé que le marshall
avatar a confirmé son attachement cessez
le feu nous avons soutenu dès le début
l'idée de cette conférence à berlin
parce que plus on tient plus de pays
c'est de d'aider les libyens à régler le
conflit
mieux c'est pour le résultat est bien
sûr en se basant sur cette idée nous
allons participer à la conférence de ce
dimanche à berlin nous avons participé à
toutes les cinq rencontres préliminaires
les textes provisoire à mon avis on sont
bien prêts sont était pratiquement
validé par toutes les parties
ces textes correspondent aux décisions
du conseil de sécurité sur le règlement
les biens ces documents ne contiennent
pas de clause qui serait contraire aux
décisions de l'as du conseil de sécurité
nous avons essayé n'est ce pas de deux
bien préparé cet texte
j'espère qu'après la conférence de
berlin si le conseil de sécurité
soutient cette décision il faut enfin
que les parties libyennes ne répète plus
leurs erreurs de l'époque et ne ne
s'accuse pas pour l'instant les six
libyens dans des conflits troncs des
relations très tendues ne veulent pas
même être présent dans la même salle
alors avec nos collègues italiens nous
allons participer à cette conférence
g
prévu rencontre à berlin avec le
ministre dit maillot avant le début de
cette conférence
al manar votre question al manar
monsieur lavrov
félicitations à l'occasion de la
nouvelle année continue des propositions
du président russe
concernant les modifications de la
constitution et la nomination du nouveau
premier ministre selon bousculera une
nouvelle doctrine de la politique
étrangère russe
parce que en russie peut-être la
politique étrangère est choisi par le
président est déterminé par le président
mais en pratique continue de droit
international parce que nous sommes
habitués à ce que vous dites souvent que
vous soutenez la le droit international
parce que cela contribue à renforcer là
sur une tête de la fédération de russie
et vous dites que il ya des choses qu'il
faut faire pour défendre les intérêts de
la russie
quels seront les changements après ces
événements est une autre question au
liban il a eu des manifestations où les
rebelles pour la première fois à ont
presque à temps les frontières du
l'ambassade russe au liban est-ce que
c'est peut être symbolique pour cette
raison les forces qui c'est d'imposer
quelque chose et peut-être c'est une
tentative de renvoyer un message à la
russie
votre première question j'étais jeune
notre président a déjà émis des
commentaires sur notre relation 93 les
rapports entre le droit international et
la constitution russe la conventionnelle
russe a bien précisé
c'est une norme qui régit nos actions et
aucun accord international ne doit être
contraire à la constitution russe mais
je voudrais attirer votre attention
faites suivant tout accord international
que la russie accepte à laquelle la
russie se joint à signer devra être
ratifié par le parlement russe par
l'assemblée fédérale cette ratification
[Musique]
est validée par une loi russe et donc
nos engagements internationaux
désormais font partie de notre système
juridique parce que cette présence forme
d'une loi fédérale aux 7 laux fédéral ne
peut pas être adoptée si elle est
contraire à la constitution russe donc
je ne vois pas de de fondement pour pour
des spéculations quant au liban
l'institution au liban eh bien nous
avons évalué les efforts gens vont
apprécier les efforts des dirigeants des
forces spéciales libanaise après cet
incident jeu
veut pas avancer des théories de complot
apparemment à côté de l'ambassade russe
il y à un centre de tensions et de
l'aimant les participants à ces
manifestations ne voulait libérer ces
gens et c'est comme ça que justement ces
deux engins se sont retrouvés sur le
territoire sur le terrain de l'ambassade
et de l'ambassade n'a pas souffert du
tout et les services les monnaies ont
permis promis de bien protéger
l'ambassade on rachète des bons jours la
chaîne arte mais cela va vous avez
commencé votre discours en parlant des
turbulences est vraiment l'année passée
nous avons vu les manifestations partout
dans le monde amérique latine
hong kong partout mais la question clé
c'est pourquoi nous voyons ces processus
et qui est un tollé à l'origine de çà de
cette contamination
nous avons vu que ces sentiments sont en
cité par 20 minuten et maintenant
l'année 2020 a commencé nous voyons les
un nouvel événement la crise entre les
etats-unis et l'iran et j'ai une
question
ce que nous devons
nous être préoccupé par ces tendances
est-ce que la situation comme on venu
cela peut se répéter
et quel est le sort de l'iran vous savez
il est difficile de faire des pronostics
là-dessus victoire tu mardin de
bienheureuse mémoire a dit un jour c'est
très ingrat de faire des pronostics
surtout pour les pronostics pour le
futur surtout pour l'avenir alors
pronostics surtout pour l'avenir surtout
par rapport à ce que vont faire nos
collègues américains
difficile de faire ce pronostic de
visiter quelques actions américain est
difficile de prévoir ce qu'ils vont
appliquer comme politique cette année
mais rond peut rien exclure
j'ai déjà cité à plusieurs reprises que
les américains essaient de remplacer le
droit international par les airs règles
pour créer un ordre mondial que souhaite
l'occident cette tentative de freiner la
formation d'un nouvel ordre mondial
polycentrique multicentrique l'occident
c'est de freiner la l'apparition de
nouvelles puissances importante le
dialogue commercial entre la chine et
les etats-unis est assez difficile
c'est un organe de règlement de conflits
qui existent depuis depuis plusieurs
années mais depuis un an cet organe ne
fonctionne pratiquement pas parce que
les états unis bloquent la nomination de
membres de cet organe et qui a pas de
quorum atteint alors au lieu de résoudre
les problèmes du commerce international
via un mécanisme
il ya dans ce levier bien établie
internationale les états unis préfèrent
régler les relations avec les
concurrents un à un la commission
européenne notamment vient d'émettre ses
réserves à ses préoccupations sur cet
accord américano chinois qui vient
d'être atteint est ce que ceci ne viole
pas les règles de l'homme sait mais si
l'on parle de la sécurité internationale
à proprement parler si l'on parle de la
non prolifération et bien il y à des
tentatives de mener ce jeu unilatérale
pour ne pas permettre une vraie
transparence un dialogue transparent
universelle qui lui seul pourrait
arriver pourrait permettre de obtenir un
consensus
regardez ce qui se passe dans
l'organisation pour l'interdiction des
armes chimiques
le secrétariat empêcher la convention
sur l'interdiction des armes chimiques
ne fonctionne pratiquement pas là le
même sort apparemment atteint la
convention sur l'interdiction des armes
biologiques de toxines les américains
bloc cette décision il veut c'est à
travers le secrétariat de ces
organisations nationales le secrétariat
de l'union notamment à travers des
mécanismes bilatéraux non transparent
très opaque de faire avancer leurs
intérêts notamment dans l'espace
postsoviétique des laboratoires
biologiques sont créés avec la
participation de pentagone notamment
c'est très sérieux c'est très
préoccupant pour le monde mais les
américains ne veulent pas que cette ce
processus soit sous contrôle comment de
tous les
pays signataires de la convention sur
l'interdiction des armes biologiques
vous venez de mentionner l'iran
il existe bien cet accord sur le
nucléaire iranien le gcp hoa qui était
validée par le conseil de sécurité cette
résolution porte en caractère
juridiquement contraignant c'est ça le
droit international
or les américains ont décidé de sortir
de ce plan de cet accord et ils ont
cessé ce pas d'observer leurs
engagements et ils interdisent d'autres
pays de faire du commerce avec les rangs
mais ils veulent par contre que l'iran
continue d'observer lé document qui a
été appelé par le présentera comme le
pire du monde de l'histoire alors les
américains veulent que tous les pays
cesse de faire commerce avec les rangs
or l'iran doit selon eux continuer à
appliquer les règles prescrites par cet
accord
cette situation est d'autant plus cette
situation d'autant plus dangereuse que
la grande bretagne la france et
l'allemagne des trois pays européens
membres de ce mécanisme viennent de
envoyé une lettre à monsieur orel en
disant qu'il veut lancer la procédure de
règlement de litiges prévues par ce
mécanisme
c'est une lettre confidentielle mais on
sait que cette cette lettre a été
envoyée le présent poutine a prévenu à
plusieurs reprises et lady town est un
prince
les européens
[Musique]
allez utiliser une situation autour de
l'iran une action iranien quelconque
pour accuser l'iran de tout ce qui s'est
passé
l'iran ou et on l'a répété à plusieurs
reprises a suspendu uniquement
l'application des engagements qui ont
été les engagements livre les
engagements unilatéraux de léran tout ce
qui se fait en iran dans le domaine
nucléaire est tout à fait transparent
ceci se passe en présence des
inspecteurs de reuil
l'iran est un pays qui est le plus
inspectez si vous voulez d'être tous les
pays signataires nombre de l'accord de
non prolifération alors ces trois pays
européens
lorsque ils ont proclamé que c'est
l'iran qui était temps bléger de prendre
des mesures et suri l'on regrettait la
sortie de dos les rangs de ce mécanisme
mais il accuse maintenant l'iran alors
hier seulement j'ai lu cette nouvelle
comme quoi le la ministre de défense
allemande vient de confirmer les rumeurs
selon lequelles avant d'écrire cette
lettre adressée par les trois ministres
des affaires étrangères les américains
ont posé un ultimatum à ses trophées
européens en menaçant des taxes des
droits de douane de 25% pour les
voitures pour notamment l'automobile les
produits de ces trois pays
si ces pays ne veulent garder le
mécanisme dont il on sonne l'a dit tout
à fait ouvertement oublions cet accord
obama réalisons un nouvel accord selon
trempe les méthodes qu'utilisent nos
partenaires américains sont
multiples sont très variées je sais pas
prévoir ce qui ce qui va se passer mais
nous continuons le dialogue avec les
américains et les européens sur tous les
problèmes
récemment les vice ministres des
affaires étrangères des états unis et de
la russie ont eu une réunion pour
discuter tous les problèmes à l'ordre du
jour et notamment
ils ont discuté le concept de la
prédictabilité alors les résultats ne
sont pas énormes pour l'instant mais le
dialogue continu et nous allons être
ferme pour ne pas laisser le monde notre
monde sans son accord quelconque qui de
quelque manière que ce soit contrôler la
non prolifération d'armes nucléaires
l' arme de destruction massive
le président dans son message
spécialement souligné le rôle des cinq
pays membres permanents du conseil de
sécurité
parce que selon la charte de l'onu un
privilège c'est une énorme
responsabilité d'être membre permet
d'avoir le droit de veto c'est une
grande responsabilité qu'on ne peut pas
prendre un léger il faut assumer cette
responsabilité là l'appel du président
russe et donc de l'appel aux cinq pays
membres du permanent c'est d'assumer
leurs responsabilités de comprendre la
lourdeur de la charge
il faut que cet appel soit entendu dans
votre question bonjour monsieur l'avoir
je m'appelle facile polanski et la
chaîne lost j'ai une question concernant
la révolution africaine l assassinat de
nos trois collègues journalistes et
récemment on a reçu l'information selon
laquelle la police locale a brûlé les
vêtements des trois journalistes qui
était un jeu preuve importants d une
question est ce que le mr russe des
affaires étrangères a demandé
à poser des questions cons sans cet
incident à vos collègues de la
république centrafricaine oui bien sûr
non nous sommes adressés aux autorités
de la république centrafricaine
je ne connais pas cette histoire des
brûlures et des vêtements
le dossier pénal maintenant est intenté
par les enquêteurs russes nous avons
émis des commentaires et nous avons
souhaité que les organismes compétents à
savoir le comité d' enquêtes devraient
être impliquées dans cette enquête et
créer des avoirs des conditions pour
séjourner dans d'autres pays et nous
avons prévenu les journalistes et les
gens d'autres métiers que quand vous
demandez votre visage votre demande doit
être conforme à l'objectif de votre
objectif c'est une tragédie bien sûr et
nous allons faire tout notre possible
pour que la vérité soit établie
le métier de journaliste c'est un métier
dangereux
c'est vrai il y à des journalistes qui
auront péri mais il faut comprendre que
les journalistes doivent devrait au
moins informé l'état russe ou est ce que
vous vous êtes ou est-ce que vous
voyagez pour être en sécurité
je vous le conseille donc si surtout
vous voyagez dans des pays en conflit
qui est de votre question l'agencé kyodo
bonjour mais cela prouve l'agencé
japonaise à kyoto shing âgées une
question concernant les négociations
avec le japon
l'année passée quand vous êtes vu un
japon un envoyé vous avez dit que à la
partie russe a donné la liste de vos
préoccupations à la partie japonaise et
parmi ses préoccupations se sont se sont
la prise c'est la présence des matériaux
militaire américaine au japon
et quelles garanties et le japon doit-il
donner à la partie russe pendant la
négociation selon vous est il y a des
relations de l'alliance entre le japon
et les états unis mais est ce que c'est
possible d'éliminer ses préoccupations
vous avez tous en fait vous avez tout
dit mais en en fait c'est une question
bien grave
c'est un volet très important de notre
dialogue avec le japon non seulement
dans le cadre de la conclusion d'un
accord de paix mais en général nous ne
voudrions pas que le territoire de notre
bon voisin qui est le japon représente
la menace pour la russie bien sûr il ya
une préoccupation de notre part et qui
ont été formulées et qui sont abordés
dans le cadre de dialogue à entre les
vice ministres des affaires étrangères
et dans le cadre du dialogue au niveau
des secrétaires des des conseils de
sécurité
hier le secrétaire général du conseil de
sécurité japonais à séjourner à moscou
il a et s'est entretenu avec monsieur
pas trop cher
de quoi s'agit-il vous avez mentionné le
fait qu'on installe les systèmes
antimissile américain sur le territoire
japonais
basés au sol et depuis longtemps nos
collègues japonais prétendent eux qui le
font pour être protégés contre la menace
qu'ils viennent du péninsule coréenne et
ses systèmes antimissiles seront gérés
par la partie japonaise par les forces
d'autodéfense japonaises dans ses
aspects nos essayons d'établir et
des détails concrets mais en effet et on
achète des systèmes antimissile
américain les rampes anti de dire
antimissile qui ont été essayées déjà
par les états unis pour lancer des
missiles de croisière c'est donc une
armée qui a été interdite par le traité
est finie quant à l'époque où ce traité
rester encore en vigueur c'est donc la
possibilité de lancer des missiles de
croisière à proximité de nos frontières
cela nous préoccupe il n'y a pas de
soupçon que les autorités japonaises et
l'élite politique caresse certaines
intentions agressives face à la russie
mais il y à une union de défense entre
le japon et les etats-unis comme vous
l'avait dit et si vous consultez les
documents et les déclarations dans le
cadre du partenariat entre le japon et
les états unis vous allez voir que les
états unis utilisent ce partenariat pour
la dissuasion de la russie pour les
américains la russie c'est un adversaire
et
japon fait partie de cette stratégie et
bien sûr nous voulons une clarté et
comprendre de quelle façon
notre coopération ultérieure va se
développer avec le japon ici les
américains essayez de pour que de faire
en sorte pour que le japon fait partie
de cette politique adverse à la russie
ce but ce dialogue est très important
nous voulons une clarté mardi le
processus commencé au sénat américain
certains disent que cela va contribuer à
renforcer les positions russes après je
ne sais pas la destitution c'est chez
vous vous êtes américaine vous êtes
mieux placé la chaîne giiks tv brice en
octobre 2019 vous avez dit que à les
brics c'est le meilleur exemple de la
diplomatie multilatérale selon vous
quels sont les le plus grand la réussite
des brics est ce qu'il y a des objectifs
déjà fixés
je ne vais pas abuser de votre temps
puisque
c'est une question très concrète sur le
site de notre présidence aux brics vous
pouvez trouver notre programme et en
complément nous pouvons diffuser ce
programme et est donc vous aurez toutes
les réponses
pour cela vous pouvez consulter notre
site un homme nous avons plus d'une
centaine de manifestations dans le cadre
de la présidence non seulement à moscou
et à saint pétersbourg mais dans notre
bilan à l'oral par exemple il ya eu des
rencontres au niveau ministériel et je
crois que le sommet qui va couronner
notre présidence ça sera à mi juin à
saint pétersbourg
ça sera un grand événement si votre
question est maintenue ce n'est sur
lavrov
hier il était accusé la russie d'avoir
falsifié l'histoire de la seconde guerre
mondiale mais très souvent ce sont les
pays baltes qui essaient de falsifier
l'histoire et les ordinations
internationale après un contre leur avis
et cela mène à l'adoption du moment
comme celui qui a été adopté par
l'assemblée parlementaire il ya à hasnon
mais comment la russie peut défendre et
ses intérêts dans ce contexte qu'est ce
que nous devons faire
vous savez comment nous avons permis
cette tendance le développement du néo
nazisme en europe occidentale
nous ne pouvons pas
modifier cette situation mais nous
pouvons parler de la haute mais on
esquive ce dialogue
on parle de la liberté d'expression du
respect de la liberté d'expression
et quant à l'assemblée générale nous
proposons une résolution sur
l'interdiction de la généralisation
odieux mais on agissements ils votent
contre les américains votre contre et
les secrets liao aussi les américains ne
peuvent pas avoir ne peut ne doivent
aucunement avoir à qu'une restriction
tandis que les ukrainiens
en fait en réalité se tiennent les
forces radicales qui sont très
influentes en ukraine quand vous dites
que les organismes internationaux
soutiennent ces sept ans dans ce jeu ne
sied pas d'accord
les organismes internationaux comme
l'assemblée générale des nations unies à
part majorité des voix 140 130 adopte
une résolution qui condamne tout tout
phénomène qui concerne le néonazisme
le parlement européen est un organisme
international mais qui n'est pas
universelle et beaucoup de choses se
passent là dessus sur initiative d'une
minorité
on fait référence aux règles du
consensus et du respect des opinions de
l'autre mais cette minorité très
agressive
vous avez raison les pays baltes et
certains autres pays
jo le premier violon comme on dit là
dessus mais concernant les faits réels
qui ont été mis en évidence par le
président poutine en octobre de l'année
dernière c'était une réaction de au
voleur qui sait qu'il est
voleur mais qui accuse les autres n'est
basée sur les faits réels ce sont les
données qui ont été conservés par les
archives russes
hier le ministère de la défense le
mystérieux russe a publié les archives
qui est témoigne de la libération de
varsovie à la partie polonaise par la
voix de leurs diplomates avaient
l'intérêt de prendre la connaissance de
ses archives alors on a publié ses
archives et nous sommes très intéressés
par le pignon de la partie polonaise
après avoir pris connaissance avec ces
documents mais toute tentative de
falsifier l'histoire et de démettre le
mensonge vis-à-vis de notre pays les
tentatives d'utiliser ce mensonge pour
affaiblir les positions de la russie
vont poursuivre la semaine prochaine à
jérusalem il ya eu un événement
international avec la participation du
président poutine pour honorer la
mémoire des victimes de la shoah et nous
savons que les collègues polonais tandis
que le président polonais ne serait pas
présent d'ailleurs mais nous savons que
les collègues polonais essayait de
convaincre les participants occidentaux
les américains certains et leader
européen pour que dans leurs
déclarations ils se tiennent le point de
vue polonais sur les approches russe
historique qui concerne la seconde
guerre mondiale ces méthodes sont
insolente
vu les événements dans dans le cadre ils
peuvent faire cette tentative à votre
question kazakhstan et kazakhstan dans
le cadre de plusieurs opérations a pu à
faire revenir de la syrie à 600 citoyens
y compris 400 enfants et la même
situation avec le lire à l'irak nous
avons un fait revenir à nos citoyens
comment on veut lui et vous les
activités du kazakhstan pour faire venir
ses citoyens de cette région
ce sont des actes qui doivent être
entreprises peuvent être entrepris par
un taux aux états souverains pourraient
remplir les obligations devant leurs
citoyens nous faisons de même non
militaire de services spéciaux et non
un commissaire aux droits des enfants au
fond tout leur possible pour faire
revenir nos enfants de l'ira de layrac
de chéri je reviens de l'ouzbékistan et
nos amis ouzbeks au fond d'eux mêmes ils
font revenir leurs citoyens les épouses
les enfants les combattants c'est un
sujet à part tout ce qui se passe à
l'est en syrie actuellement quand les
combattants sont dispersés mais quand il
s'agit des femmes et des enfants
mais ces femmes ont été endoctrinés et
ils se sont retrouvés non pas de leur
propre volonté et bien sûr elles veulent
revenir chez elle pour que leurs enfants
soient éduqués comme des gens normaux et
non pas endoctrinés par thésée des
terroristes félicitations à tout le
monde au ministère russe je pense que
sans vous sans votre ministère le monde
pour être encore pire à je voudrais un
poser une question concernant la
politique polonaise à l'égard des
cimetières des monuments parce que
pologne 1 récemment un un petit corner a
dit qu'il était prêt à venir en russie
et nous voyons qu'il ne vient pas mais
qu'est ce que vous en pensez est-ce que
vous quel est votre avis sur ce compte
cette attitude envers les monuments j'ai
déjà parlé de ce problème de relation
aux résultats de la deuxième guerre
mondiale
je suis persuadé qu'il faut s'appuyer
uniquement sur le fait historique
dialogue basé sur les documents qu'ils
proviennent des archives
nous sommes toujours ouverts à ce
dialogue nous avons maintenu pendant
longtemps tout une structure avec nos
collègues polonais structure de
communication dont le comité stratégique
qui était dirigée par les ministres
affaires étrangères avec la
participation d'autres administrations
également au sein de structures
il y avait un groupe d'historiens un
groupe conjoint qui étaient chargés de
questions difficiles questions du passé
mais qui toujours à conserver c'est
notre position en s'appuyant sur les
fêtes scientifiques sur le fait
historique
ce groupe a été même préparé un manuel
comme un conjoint sur des périodes d
épisode des relations russo polonaises
des articles conjoints ont été préparés
ont été préparés il ya bien sûr des
épisodes il ya eu des divergences entre
les historiens et on a publié la proche
russe l'approchent polonaise je crois
que ce travail doit être renouvelé ce
travail doit être repris et ce travail
ne devrait pas être otage
cette tentative de transformer
l'histoire en propagande
malheureusement lorsque nos collègues
polonais détruisent des monuments 7 6
une position si vous voulez et des
arguments sont avancés
donc voilà pologne n'a jamais promis de
protéger le monument qui ne sont pas
dans les cimetières et que la pologne
près uniquement à protéger les monuments
qui sont dans les cimetières
mais c'est une approche trop qui n'a pas
de fondations mon avis profonde et si
l'on conserve cette approche c'est qu'on
oublie notre dignité
il ya des gens qui sont morts pour la
libération de l'europe et leur mémoire
doit être protégé je partage la position
de ceux notamment du président tchèque
milos zeman qui se prononce contre la
destruction des monuments de soldats
quand tu as les cheveux les a c'est une
personne respectée qui a toujours été
connue et qui est toujours connu comme
un politicien à libre indépendant qui
n'a pas peur d'eux d'avancé sa position
son point de vue s'y est intéressé par
une visite en fédération de russie
je crois que ce sera ça la position sa
décision et nous serons heureux de
faciliter pleinement son séjour en
russie quant aux rencontres au niveau
politique c'est pas la question à me
poser le service allemand de spoutnik
permettez moi de ne pas me lever
ce qui m'intéresse c'est bien sûr votre
évolution des relations entre la russie
et l'allemagne la coopération après la
visite récente de madame merkel est ce
qu'il ya une percée ils n'ont pas ce que
après c'est la première visite dans cinq
ans vous savez déjà que les contacts
entre le président russe et la
chancelière allemande dans les
conditions habituelles besoin d'être
axée sur une percée forcément le
président du ces chaussures allemande
parle souvent dans le cadre d'événements
différents à paris notamment
ils ont souvent des conversations
téléphoniques
ce sont des relations très pragmatiques
sont les relations de travail personnes
essaient de persuader l'autre du fait
que c'est moi qui ai toujours raison
personne ne pousse l'autre à régler
d'abord les principes et des eaux
logique il ya des sanctions il ya une
prise de position allemande que
l'allemagne adopté après le coup d'état
en ukraine qui se déroulait d'ailleurs
dans une situation où la pulsion de
l'allemagne a été ignorée finalement et
que l'allemagne était considéré par les
putschistes comme un pays qui comme un
pays presque inexistant parce que
l'allemagne était l'un des garants de
l'accord qu'ensuite les sens qui ont
perpétré le putsch ont abandonné mais
l'allemagne finalement à accepter
finalement
malheureusement cet acte illégal
perpétrés
contre sa volonté et l'allemagne a
commencé à considérer la crise
l'ukrainienne sous un autre angle de vue
lorsque les habitants de l'acte i mais
ont voté au référendum pour le retour en
fédération de russie c'est ça le point
de départ non collègues occidentaux
compte cette histoire partir de ce point
là mais mais il faut aller plus en
arrière
leder dieu du coup d'état on sera dos
peut-être issus d'une loi qui cessait
toute garantie pour la population
russophone et que les nationalistes
ukrainiens ont dit russe qui est l acte
i mais allez vous en parce que certains
en occident soutenu le putsch en parlant
de la visite de la chancelière merkel
cette visite n'était pas un événement
extraordinaire
effectivement non collègues allemands
c'est surtout intéressés par la bonne
tenue de la conférence de berlin sur la
libye nous avons prêté beaucoup
d'attention et puis lorsque la le
président russe de chansons allemandes
ont parlé à dos et nous on a parlé avec
mon collègue heiko maas et son équipe
nous ont parlé de l'économie également
ils ont parlé énergie nordstream de la
conférence de presse
[Musique]
l'introduction est dans les réponses aux
questions on a bien compris c'est le
pragmatisme qui prime dans nos relations
avec le mal lagence autrichienne 1
prenait le micro s'il vous plaît
appuyez sur le bouton la division
autrichienne
parce que je peux poser de questions
vous avez parlé de léran vous avez
critiqué les états unis et à trois pays
européens mais vous n'avez pas dit que
c'est la russie vous ne vous n'avez pas
dit ce que la russie peut faire afin
d'éviter l'escaladé dans leurs relations
avec l'iran et la deuxième question
séjour c'est la formation du
gouvernement russe
est-ce que vous restez dans votre post
des ministres vous êtes journaliste
depuis longtemps comprenez bien tout le
monde a ri un peu je suis ministre par
intérim depuis trois jours vingt pages
sur cet intérim quant à les reins
je suis sûr que vous suivez nos
initiatives
la déclaration nous considérons qu'il
est inacceptable que ce que nous
considérons que ce qui se passe avec
l'accord sur le terrain est inacceptable
l'idée c'était de léran limite son
programme nucléaire
selon quelques paramètres quant au
volume du de lourdes
quant à l'uranium à 4%
l'iran s'engage et s'engager à suivant
des normes supérieures aux engagements
normand et en réponse on a promis aux
iraniens uniquement de ne ne pas imposer
des limitations supplémentaire au
commerce
l'occident a juste promis 2
levée des limitations pour le commerce
par contre ensuite les états unis ont
pratiquement interdit à tout le monde de
faire le commerce avec les rangs il
menace de sanctions les européens ont
essayé d'avancer leur position ils ont
proposé un mécanisme qui permettra de
desservir ce commerce en évitant de
l'art de ce mécanisme a été créé ce
mécanisme s'appelle hince tex le savez
ceux ci a été créé uniquement pour
desservir des les transactions qui
concerne les marchandises humanitaires
qui ne tombe même pas sous le coup des
sanctions américaines
ensuite on a dit lorsque le mécanisme
commencera à fonctionner ce mécanisme
permettra de desservir d'autres types de
commerces dans le pétrole
mais depuis un an ce mécanisme n'a
permis de réaliser aucune transaction
une transaction et a débuté mais l'a
toujours pas ça s'est terminé qui
concernent des médicaments pour 10
millions de dollars uniquement c'est une
petite goutte dans l'océan
alors lorsque les vents dit qu'il va
suspendre la mise en pratique de ces
engagements supplémentaires
nous pensons que ceci incite si vous
voulez les américains appuyés plus de
pression nous voyons bien quelles sont
les causes de cette action
indésirable de léran l'iran pourtant
notons le n'abandonne pas ses
engagements qui sont les engagements
obligatoire pour tous les pays membres
la convention sur la non prolifération
nous pensons que les opéras les
européens peuvent faire plus qu'ils ne
font aujourd'hui bien sûr les haussiers
de décision d
un organisme qui vais les entreprises
privées ne vont pas faire le commerce à
la perte s il ya des entreprises qui
vont des investissements aux etats-unis
par exemple ou bien que leurs
transactions passent par le dollar
c'est la lente reprise qui prend sa
décision sur qu'elle marchait cette
entreprise va travailler on comprend
bien quelle sera sa décision mais il ya
des entreprises qui n'ont pas
d'engagement qui n'ont pas d'intérêt
dans les territoires sur lesquels les
législateurs américains au long leur
influence nous sommes en train de
discuter notamment de la question de
l'avenir de cette situation non
représentant les vice ministres des
affaires étrangères sont en contact
permanent avec le service des affaires
étrangères européens qui coordonne les
actions dans le cadre de cet accord sur
le nucléaire iranien
j'espère voir jeu cocon doivent tenir
prochainement une réunion pour essayer
de comprendre qu'ils pensent quoi et qui
fait quoi
parce que nos partenaires occidentaux
les les trois pays occidentaux 30
bretagne france et allemagne assure que
leurs actions que leurs critiques
lorsqu'il demande de l'iran n'ont qu'un
seul objectif c'est de préserver le
genevois de la cour sur rien et pourtant
boris johnson parallèlement lorsque les
trois capitales ont dit cela
don johnson a dit et si on annuler
l'accord obama et s'ils ont conclu un
nouvel accord selon 30
ensuite ils ont essayé d'annuler cette
déclaration de démentir cette
déclaration et pourtant et pourtant
société deal allemands sont bien tombés
je pense qu'au togo minimum il faut
organiser une réunion des directeurs
politiques deux des trois pays européens
de la chine la russie et bien sûr de
l'iran est de parler franchement times
of india
s'il vous plaît et après la visite
d'hier
quelles sont vos impressions avec la
réunion avec monsieur moody est ce que
vous avez réussi à vous entendre sur
l'utilisation de 1 mo nationale est dans
la com le commerce est entre la russie
et l'inde est la deuxième question
quelle est votre réaction à des
tentatives d'évoquer la question du
cachemire à au conseil de sécurité de
l'onu yeux la première tentative a eu
lieu en août 2019
et quelle est votre position sur la
réforme constitutionnelle de landes qui
change le statut du cachemire quant à
ces négociations à new delhi pour parler
avec le premier ministre nous dit le
ministre en cherchant car nous n'avons
pas vraiment parler du commerçant devise
nationale nous avons des mécanismes
intergouvernementaux pour desservir
notre commerce et nous avons la
commission mixte intergouvernementale
elle va siéger cette année encore le
travail de cette commission est assez
régulier intense
nous avons discuté des sujets plus
politiques sur notre joie du jour
interactions dans le cadre de
l'organisation de coopération de
shanghai dans le brix surtout compte
tenu du fait que la russie président et
les deux organisations
cette année et puis nous avons parlé de
l'instution de la région
la région asie pacifique y compris cette
nouvelle à ce nouveau terme qui vient
d'arriver
c'est le terme de la région indo
pacifique
c'est un terme avancé par les dons
collègues américains comme le terme au
drame vous mondial basé sur les règles
c'est un nouveau terme également la même
chose pour ce terme indo pacifique mais
nous n'avons pas discuté
notre vision des ternes des noms de
concept nous avons discuté les latitudes
russe indienne envers l'interaction
multilatérale dans notre région nord nos
approches coïncide pratiquement ni la
russie ni la ddt ne soutiennent pas
cette tentative d'utiliser le nouveau
concept stratégique indo pacifique pour
former pour créer des configurations de
conflits de confrontation l'inde et la
russie considère qu'il est important de
coopérer de continuer la coopération
avec le soutien en se basant sur les
structures déjà existantes et qui sont
qui ont été créés dans le cadre de la
séance
ils ont le forum de sécurité il ya un
mécanisme spécial pour la réunion des
ministres de la défense de la séance de
ses partenaires il y a également
l'instrument très importants comme le
sommet de l'asie de l'est qui permettent
de discuter ces problèmes
de ce point de vue donc il est très
important de comprendre que nos
positions
position indienne apposition rues sont
pratiquement identiques la terminologie
laissent un champ pour une discussion
c'est vrai j'ai déjà posé ces questions
à nos collègues américains japonais
australiens
on pourrait leur demander parce que les
états unis l'australie le japon et la
ville de corrèze qui font la promotion
de cette ce nouveau concept est ce que
ce remplacement par le terme indo
pacifique est ce que ça veut dire que
l'afrique de l'est sera inclus dans ce
set
dans cette configuration est ce que ça
veut dire que le golfe persique sera
également partir de ces discussions il
ouvrait pour dieu non cela veut dire que
les participants sont à peu près les
mêmes que dans le cadre de relations
sauf que on veut mettre de nouvelles
poser de nouvelles lignes de séparation
ceux qui ont avancé ce concept ne le
cache pas tellement il est pourtant fort
est très important pas s'assurer que les
indiens le comprenons l'aghanistan
les gens soviétique selon vous comment
la crise entre l'iran les états unis
vont influer sur le processus du paix en
afghanistan
je n'ai pas encore répondu à la question
précédente
concernant les discussions autour des
problèmes de cachemire dans le conseil
de sécurité nous sommes pour le
règlement de ce conflit dans le cadre
des négociations directes entre l'inde
et le pakistan sur la base des accords
qui sont en place entre ces deux pays
c'est notre position quand quelqu'un
propose d'aborder ce sujet dans les
organismes internationaux y compris des
oignons répéter votre question s'il vous
plaît vous comment la crise entre l'iran
et les états unis va enfler sur
le processus pacifique en afghanistan je
pense que la crémation des relations
entre l'iran et les états unis ne vont
pas aider au règlement dans la région
puisque la tension monte et cette
tragédie avec l'avion ukrainien c'est
une sonnette d'alarmé qui oblige toutes
les parties à commencer la désescalade
et n'ont pas envoyé des avions de combat
dans la région
mais dans le contexte pratique nous
savons que les états unis en afghanistan
représente un des acteurs principaux
ils ont leurs troupes en afghanistan et
les domine la coalition ils essaient de
négocier avec les talibans d'ailleurs
nosotros ses tentatives qui pourrait
commencer des négociations entre tous
les hommes quand c'est une condition qui
a été posé par les talibans et qui a été
accepté
nous essayons de soutenir ce processus
et en parallèle un à un en utilisant nos
propres contacts avec les talibans que
nous incitons à
vous entamez un dialogue direct avec les
autres forces politiques en afghanistan
nous avons des canaux de discussions
avec les américains et les chinois avec
une participation toute récente dieu
pakistan et il serait correct ici non
seulement les etats-unis la russie et le
pakistan et la chine soit capable de
parler de la position de la possibilité
de règlement mais que l'iran participe
également à ce processus
ça pourrait être possible mais ce qui
empêche c'est la politique anti
iranienne des américains et l'absence de
volonté de l'iran de parler avec les
américains et les aider dans différents
aspects de tout de tous les points de
vue il faut une désescalade dans les
relations entre les etats-unis et l'iran
mais pour cela il faut une sagesse
politique
je ne crois pas que si elle est
maintenant de continuer publiquement
accusé dans tous les pêchés dans la
région seulement les roms on ne pourrait
pas dé procéder à une désescalade
partout washington exige de l'era de
cesser toute action
dix ans à développer des liens ce n'est
pas réaliste tous les pays et de la
région et d'autres régions ont leurs
propres intérêts et la défense de ses
intérêts et ses très proches sont
projetés dans les relations avec leurs
voisins
mais pour ça il faut utiliser des
méthodes légaux les galets vous voyez
cette présence de la coalition
occidentale à l'est de la syrie qui
attisent les intérêts séparatistes c'est
un problème très grave qu'il vaut mieux
être à table de négociation il vaut
mieux pour tous et l'iran a proposé de
conclure à un accord de non agression
entre l'iran et les pays du golfe
ensuite les rats a proposé l'initiative
de paix dort mu pour garantir la
sécurité dans cette région nous
apportons une même la même approche
notre concept de sécurité dans la région
du golfe et dans les régions
avoisinantes
il s'agit non seulement de la nécessité
de réunir autour d'une table de
négociations tous les pays arabes du
golfe et l'iran mais aussi soutenir les
efforts avec la participation d de la
ligue arabe à l'organisation de
coopération islamique
les cinq membres du conseil de sécurité
l'union européenne
je crois que dans cette configuration on
pourrait relancer le travail d'une
conférence sur la sécurité et de la
confiance dans cette région et ensuite
et si ce processus réussissent réussi on
pourrait faire participer d'autres pays
de la région et élargir
la participation avec les pays de
l'afrique du nord
malheureusement les contradictions entre
certains et pays arabes et l'iran sont
assez profonde dans nos contacts avec
l'arabie séoudite avec les émirats
arabes unis et avec élira un nouveau
prononçons pour le dialogue et le
commencement du dialogue a entre ces
deux pays
ils le comprennent en évidence mais pour
le moment nous n'avons pas réussi à
convaincre nos amis de relance et ceux
travaillant le journal britannique
independent' j'espère que la question ne
pas sur la sphère skripal
je voudrais poser une question sur le
bruit ne craignant pas ce que la semaine
passée
tout le monde a parlé de ce sujet on a
comparé la proche de l'iran et de la
russie à ces situations avec 17 de
manière pas très positive et je voudrais
demander si vous êtes si vous partagez
le pignon de margarita simonian selon
lesquelles les reins agit comme un
nouvel homme à la différence des autres
y compris la russie
et je voudrais aussi vous poser une
question concernant la position du
ministère des affaires étrangères parce
que certains diplomates ont dit que
c'était juste la désinformation de la
part de l'occident bien qu'il y avait
beaucoup de preuves beaucoup de
témoignages
même sans avoir accès aux renseignements
classifiés qu'il ya eu
catastrophe sans parler des images
donc c'est pas vrai et la question et si
vous croyez qu'il est nécessaire de
présenter des excuses au spi des
personnes tuées
le pignon sur les propos de simonian
voilà ce qui m'intéresse mais ce que tu
dis indépendante qui un est le
propriétaire de votre quotidien
je ne me rappelle pas si notre ministère
des affaires étrangères presque huit ans
que cette version c'est une
désinformation
ce n'était pas le cas vous pouvez
démentir avec la déclaration
c'est le vice ministre jan kopecky et le
disais je ne me rappelle pas il n'y
avait pas de déclaration officielle non
il n'y avait pas de déclaration
officielle et tim adams zakharova nos
sessions pour l'établissement de la
vérité comme nous voulons la vérité
concernant la le boeing malaisien vous
savez j'ai répondu à la question
précédente et j'ai évoqué la tragédie
avec les lions d'ukrainiens dans le
contexte de cette tension entre les
etats-unis et l'iran jeu oui oui bien
sûr c'était une erreur humaine est le
monde l'a compris
oui et les réclame une indemnisation
est ce le droit des familles et je crois
que la partie iranienne ne va étudier
cette possibilité ils ont reconnu la
suite à une erreur humaine
ne voudrait convaincre personne que tout
le monde ne le voulait pas mais les
américains ont détruit à la suite d'une
opération à précédente à l'encontre de
toute voie internationale le général
souleymane sy les iraniens ont répondu
d'une manière de manière mesurée
ayant prévenu layrac et même les métiers
a prétendu que les américains étaient
prévenus et c'était donc une réalité qui
s'est passé mais il y a eu
renseignements que qu'au moment où après
cette attaque
les iraniens attendait encore une frappe
américaine et ils ne savaient pas en
quelle forme mais il ya eu au minimum
six avions f-35 dans l'espace aérien
dans la première entre entre l'iran et
l'irak que c'était une information à
vérifier mais tout simplement je
voudrais souligner cette tension qui
présente toujours dans des situations
pareilles il ya une approche iranienne
est une précieuse je ne sais pas je n'ai
pas compris
de quelles différences vaut parler à
l'instar de bruyne et criaient nous
voulons une clarté avec le pauline
malaisien et je vous rappelle certaines
choses donc nos collègues
en tout cas particulier les hollandais
les néerlandais passe sous silence
d'abord la russie était l'auteur de la
résolution adoptée par le conseil de
sécurité avec l'exigence de mener l
enquête conformément aux normes de
l'organisation de l'aviation civile est
ko et mais on ne respecte pas ces normes
dans cette résolution vous trouvez
l'exigence que ceux qui mènent l'enquêté
à rendre compte régulièrement au conseil
de sécurité il n'y a eu pas ce ces cas
de rentrer compte on a formé le couple
kate le cren l'australie la belgique les
pays-bas la malaisie à laquelle
appartenait le bruit n'était pas invitée
elle était invitée
six mois après mais non pas pour
participer à ce groupe d' enquêtes
pénales mais seulement pour participer à
un groupe qui est lucide des paramètres
techniques de cette catastrophe
nous avons posé une question pourquoi si
la russie est impliquée donc la russie
pourrait être invité et tellement on ne
nous attendait pas mais là aussi
coopérer avec ce groupe une enquête est
tout ce qui a été demandé par ce groupe
est en quête à la russie qui a été
constitué par les pays-bas a été réalisé
en russie
nous avons même procédé à une sorte de
simulation la société almaz hantée qui
fabrique le missile antiaérien books a
montré comment ça se passe à réalité ils
ont communiqué des paramètres des radars
nous avons posé la question où sont les
données techniques des radars iconia on
nous a répondu qu'elle cerrada
sérieusement on n'existe pas et les
radars ne fonctionnait pas et ils
s'étaient connectés débrancher mise en
service mais la caméra vidéo donc qui a
été débranché le jour au lait skripal
ont été empoisonnés ensuite
cette caméra après commencé à
fonctionner nous ne comprenons pas
pourquoi la partie ukrainienne ne peut
pas communiquer le ce texte d
des liaisons radio avec les contrôleurs
de l'air je parle de certaines
conversations téléphoniques entre les
représentants russes les représentants
du dombass à cinq ans après mais les
contrôleurs aériens ukrainien ces
liaisons radios devraient être
automatiquement transmis à ce groupe est
en quête on pose une question sur les
données des satellites américaines ont
dit que ces données existent mais quand
elle a mal ici n'était pas invitée à
participer à cette enquête quatre pays
qui se sont réunis avec le cren et qui
n'ont pas même pris la peine d'en parler
mais nous savons très bien que ils se
sont entendus que toute information qui
pourrait aller à l'encontre je pourrais
être approuvée par quatre participants y
compris de craine et donc quand le
parlement néerlandais a posé une
question au gouvernement pourquoi dans
le cadre de cette enquête on ne pose pas
la question à l'ukraine sur les raisons
pour qu'elle ne pas fermer le ciel de
l'ukraine du gouvernement néerlandais
conservent le silence mais quand
l'enquète néerlandais déclare
publiquement et m'ont collé que le
ministre des affaires étrangères prétend
que la russie ne compères avec l enquête
mais quand nous présentons ce que nous
avons fait et nous demandons pour
quelles raisons et les faits ses
déclarations il nous répond la russie ne
coopèrent pas parce que la russie n'a
pas reconnu son erreur
à cette base
il nous propose et on va donc examiner
toutes ces questions qui nous intéresse
c'est ce que nous avons dit nous allons
donner des réponses mais tout ce que
j'ai évoqués nous pouvons en nous venons
en parler mais il sentait écarté il
s'esquive il disait que l enquête n'est
pas terminé mais et c'est la faute de la
russie on peut parler de l'indemnisation
est-ce que c'est l'attitude d'un homme
devrait au moins je ne sais pas je ne
pense pas quand on aborde ce sujet et le
sujet de skripal l'armé chimique en
syrie explosives ou manquant en
employant l'expression rallye la clé
c'est l'histoire
par laquelle on a commencé notre
discours au lieu du droit international
on invente les règles qui sont commodes
et ont fait pression sur les autres ce
terme était contenue que la situation de
monsieur rap comme n'a pas été correct
je voudrais citer ce qu'il a dit le 10
janvier que sergueï riabkov haïti je
suis à peu près sûr que essayer de
gagner deux points sur cette tragédie et
c'est impossible il faut que les experts
analysent la situation et puis on peut
faire les conclusions et lancer des jeux
politiques c'est pas acceptable et il a
dit qu'à ce stade on ne peut pas faire
des grandes déclarations
un beau jour à l'excès glav quoi
investit la chaîne rossiya 24 jours il
ne restera pas qu'une année jusqu'à la
fin du traité new start iii et on ne
sait pas qui se traitait ce sera
prolongée ou non et est-ce que vous
envoyez des signes on a 28 ans oui je
j'ai parlé de ce sujet encore en 2017 à
washington et en octobre monsieur rap
cover l'a abordée avec monsieur faure 2
avant-hier le vice secrétaire d'état
américain
les américains ne pose ne donne pas une
réponse définitive à cette question
reste en suspens est en permanence il
parle de la participation de la chine
danse à ces négociations mais en maintes
reprises nous avons expliqué notre
position le président russe à m reprise
a expliqué que si nous aurons l'accord
de toutes les participations de des
négociations multilatérales et on va y
participer mais ici un les américaines
estiment que sans la chine et il n'est
pas temps on n'a pas de sens de
poursuivre les négociations
si la chine voudrait participer on va
participer avec ces négociations mais la
république populaire de chine à maintes
reprises a expliqué que la structure des
forces nucléaires chinoises est
différente des forces nucléaires des
états unis et de la fédération de russie
est donc la chine ne va pas participer à
ces négociations nous respectons cette
position et ne va pas faire pression par
la chine
dans ce contexte mais je ne sais pas que
si pourquoi est les etats unis estiment
eux que la russie devrait faire pression
sur la chine pour que la chine
participent à ces négociations mais je
ne crois pas que c'est une proposition
inacceptable
ils ont des canaux de dialogue avec la
république populaire de chine tout à
l'heure ils ont conclu un accord de
commerce et je le confirme et j'en je
confirme encore une fois nous respectons
la position de la république populaire
de chine
si à un certain est apple une
configuration d'autres négociations
seraient à
concertée alors on va y participer mais
cela va prendre du temps et si les
conditions politiques soient réunies les
négociations sais c'est pas moi c'est
plus long mais dans ce nom le traitait
new start expire et donc monsieur
poutine disait à monsieur trempé et à
monsieur pour p o à sotchi
et s'il vous plaît devraient s'entendre
sur la prolongation de ce traité par que
les états unis cherchent d'autres
possibilités et le passé le précédent
que cela réaffirmé encore une fois en
automne dernier lors de la réunion d
avec les responsables des mini du
ministère de la défense ne sommes pour
la prologation du new start sans
conditions préalables et nous espérons
que les américains vont entendre la
position russe mais pour le moment je
nous n'avons pas de signe net de la part
des américains n'avons pas beaucoup de
temps deux dernières questions s'il vous
plaît plaît télévision de yamal
là aussi on va présider le conseil
arctique de 2020 en 2023 à quel
préparatifs sont effectuées dans ce
contexte quel est le rôle de nos régions
en tic y compris il ya mal et selon vous
est ce que notre agenda arctique et
efficace je crois que l'agent d'artistes
changer le résultat de travailleurs dans
grands groupes de travail et c'est
toujours d'un reflètent nos intérêts
dans le domaine de la sécurité de
navigation c'est toute l'économie du
secteur énergétique et la protection de
l'environnement et aussi la protection
des droits des peuples autochtones et
les représentants des peuples
autochtones participe au travail des
conseils d'artistes les représentants de
ces peuples ont la parole lors des
réunions ministérielles
le conseil actif j'espère que ça va
continuer et pour l'instant n'est pas
sous l'influencé des idéologies le
conseil arctique prend des décisions
très importantes sur la coopération en
état d'urgence
par exemple en se réfugiant de pétrole
dieu nous en garde sur la coopération
scientifique sur la réglementation de la
pêche dans l'océan arctique et sur
d'autres sujets nous sommes d'ailleurs
pour le renouvellement de cause de ne
pas renouveler cet engagement de
[Musique]
interdire l'arctique méthodes militaires
nous sommes contre l' implication de
l'otan dans ces latitudes et nous sommes
de toute façon toujours les rayons des
dirigeants d'état major des forces
armées des pratiques pour les spas
assurer un niveau acceptable de la
confiance de proposons de renouveler ses
consultations d'experts d'abord et
s'être ensuite les réunions des chefs
d'états-majors le concert ticket long
que poursuit cet euro nous allons
assurer la continuité c'est l'islande
maintenant qu'il dirige ce vote ce
conseil nous sommes en contact régulier
avec le ministre
donc l'on s'approche du 2021 et nous
allons former la gendarme et un qui va
assurer la continuité de ce processus
finalisé pas toutes les parties
prenantes sur l'économie sur la
protection climatique sur une protection
de l'environnement et bien sûr pour
assurer les droits les conditions de vie
des peuples autochtones
la dernière question estonie un bon jour
le seul à rome dirigeants à deux
milliards si ségo n'ya estonie et la
nature riche va à tout d'abord aux
normes de
ce podcast ayant personnellement je
voudrais remercier le ministère russe
des affaires étrangères l'ambassade de
russie en estonie maria zakharova
personnellement pour votre soutien à
scoudouc estonia à cette époque
difficile je voudrais rappeler que les
autorités italiennes veulent à porter un
des suivants justice à notre agence pour
nick estonie et la majorité de nos
employés ont dû depuis le 1er 1er
janvier rentrer leur contrat de travail
pour ne pas être poursuivi mais nous
allons continuer notre lutte est fière
votre homologue mais sorensen le
ministre estonien a parlé de situation
terrible avec les journalistes russes en
estonie et il a dit je vais citer que
cela est lié à la protection la défense
de l'europe et pour protéger la liberté
donc il faut nous mettre en prison pour
que pour que l'europe soit libre et la
dernière question dans le contexte de
ces paroles un peu diplomatique à
l'égard de la russie
à quelle votre opinion est ce que la dir
poutine va accepter la possibilité de
venir à au congrès
finau gras en estonie cette année à
l'invitation de madame la présidente
et est-ce qu'ils vont participer à
l'anniversaire de la signature de
l'accord de tartous vous avez s'était
défaite qui nous ne sommes pas vraiment
de commentaire action des autorités
estoniennes par rapport l'an spoutnik à
mon avis c'est ça suscite une
indignation non j'ai fait que dijon les
réactions de lesser il ya eu des
réactions de la part de du concert de
rock sont négatives envers l'action des
auteurs estonienne nous demandons
également l'union européenne de se
prononcer là dessus parce que ceci est à
l'encontre des valeurs annoncées de
l'union européenne apparemment l'union
européenne ne peut rien faire et ceci en
tâche encore plus la réputation de
l'union européenne cette réputation est
pas mal entaché déjà et je viens de
parler des causes de la crise craignant
notamment ce qui me préoccupe j'ai
également c'est que les partis et le
conti de l'union européenne et français
notamment avancent cette initiative hip
hop sur la soi-disant catégorisation des
médias pour établir qui fait partie des
médias et qui est l'instrument de la
propagande je crois que ça va dans la
même logique tout ce qui se passe avec
vous ce qui concerne le plan conceptuel
est proposé
au niveau des grands ministères des
grands bureaux en europe quant à
l'institution en estonie alors mon
collègue a déclaré à plusieurs reprises
que d'accord sur la frontière ne sera
pas ratifiée par ce que il vient à
l'encontre de l'accord de tartu est que
district de revenir
n'est ce pas dans la juridiction
estonienne et bien lorsque le président
a demandé d'être reçu par le président
russe à moscou
à mon avis cette discussion était tout à
fait adéquate et que le bon voisinage
préval et peut-être après le retour de
la présidente dont dans sa capitale les
choses ont changé 7
c'est triste parce que nous n'avons
jamais essayé d'abandonner la
coopération avec nos collègues
la seule chose qu'on exigeait le droit
international exige c'est n'est ce pas
de danse finir avec ce phénomène la
passe des apatrides qui entache
également la création de l'union
européenne
il ya quelques avancées sur ce sujet
parce que les personnes nées dans le bi
maintenant peuvent bénéficier de la
nationalité
ceci est pourtant assez loin des valeurs
européennes leurs collègues
le timing touche à sa fin il faut que je
gère ailleurs pour un autre événement
je vous présente mes meilleurs voeux à
l'occasion plus de nouvel an deux
petites annonces
vos questions adressées sous forme
écrite seront
aurons la réponse sur le site quelques
minutes
et bien sûr tout le monde aime de seule
fille aujourd'hui vous pourrez vous
pourrez faire de cette fille avec
monsieur lavoie je suis sûr que ça va
pas ça ne va pas affecter l'agenda du
ministre
merci